i mean every girl's been obsessed with
sports illustrated swimsuit covers they
are iconic
well kim kardashian you've manifested
yet another dream into existence
zucchini yeah she's one of the models
featured in the sports illustrated
swimsuit 2022 issue
in kim's latest magazine cover hi i'm
kim kardashian and i'm here in the
dominican republic shooting my sports
illustrated swimsuit cover the fashion
mogul didn't look too far for her beach
ensemble both the swimsuit and gloves
are courtesy of kim's billion dollar
shapewear and clothing line skims as far
as other high-powered women and models
gracing the sports illustrated cover pop
star sierra i've always jumped to being
on this cover
74 year old mother mae and model yumi
new in kim kardashian's interview with
the mag hitting newsstands may 19th she
reveals she's never seen herself as
swimsuit model material until now of
course
every time i would see magazines like
this especially in the 90s when i was
growing up it's always these perfect
tall thin women and i just have never
been that i never thought in a million
years that i would be shooting one
myself she also celebrates having this
moment nearly two years after turning 40
years old it's always like really young
girls i don't want to like date myself
or sound old but like in my 40s amid her
ongoing work in criminal justice reform
in hitting the books to become an
attorney kim's new perspective helps her
focus on what matters most when you get
to a certain age and you've been through
a certain amount of experiences
life just isn't about you anymore my
life was very much about me that's how i
lived my life and then when you get to a
certain place you're just like okay what
can i do to help other people like i'm
good
and i've gotten done what i wanted to
get done and now it's like how can i
serve and what can i do and like that is
what fulfills me as the mama 4 explains
among these priorities is setting a good
example for her kids i've always said my
goal in life is i just want to raise
kind human beings and i know with the
world that we live in that gets tested a
lot and there's some times where i'm
just like i don't want to take the high
road anymore but as hard as it is i just
would always want to lead by example
that's always my goal is to
have my kids just i just want them to be
kind people
[Music]
you